donald trump lied for five
uninterrupted minutes during yesterday's
coronavirus press briefing
about vote by mail the question came
from right-wing propaganda network
oan the way that the oan questions
typically work is that oan will
set up some completely uh distorted
softball question for donald trump or
his press secretary kaylee mckenna
sometimes the question itself is so
disjointed that you can actually see
confusion on the face of the oan
reporter asking the question like under
sometimes the reporter doesn't
understand the question
they seem confused by their own question
and it's just basically like a carte
blanche for donald trump or kaylee
mckennany
to start ranting and raving about
whatever is on their agenda this time
the question was about
vote by mail and whether trump would do
anything
at the federal level to stop vote by
mail and donald trump
five minutes going going going lying
lying
lying let's uh jump right into it oem
thank you mr president in that in our
nation's 243 year history there has
never been
a stronger push for mailing ballots to
determine a national election yeah
are you considering at any point issuing
an executive order
addressing mail-in ballots and uh why do
you think some people are pushing us
well there's never been a push like this
for mail-in ballots and if you look at
the
new york congressional race which is a
disaster
carolyn it's been a total disaster they
have
they're six weeks into it now they have
no clue what's going on
and i mean i think i can say right here
and now i think you have to rerun that
race because it's a mess nobody knows
what's happening
with the ballots and the lost ballots
and the fraudulent ballots i guess
i think you probably have to take the
carolyn maloney race and run it over
again how can you do this and this is a
small race
with literally thousands of people small
thousands and it's all messed up you
look at patterson new jersey it's all
messed up
almost every one of these and these are
small easy to control
they should be able to do this easy now
you're talking about like
nevada where last two nights ago they
they went out and in the darkness of
night without
people without having any meetings of
the public without having anything they
approved they're ridiculous you don't
have to look at signatures
you don't have to approve anything you
can have double mailings
so we're 90 seconds in here not even and
trump is lying uncontrollably he's
claiming that what nevada did is somehow
pernicious i'll talk about that later
he's talking about you know you can have
double mailings you don't need
signatures
none of that is true nevada approved
sending
absentee ballots to registered voters
who went through the normal process for
voter registration if you did it at the
registry of motor vehicles
they have your signature it was the
appropriate process there are other
opportunities of course to register to
vote you have to be a citizen all of
that stuff applies
it's just sending ballots to registered
voters
let's keep going you can have all sorts
of things nobody's ever seen anything
like it
it's a disgrace i mean honestly it's a
disgrace
so it's a very good question i mean the
the male imbalance if you look at just
some of the
small the small places the small races
congressional race in new york um
it should be very easy normally that
would have been announced at seven
o'clock and it would have been
down to the wire and everybody would
have loved it it was it was at all
complex it would have taken an extra 45
minutes or an hour they would have
announced it a little bit later
they have no clue this was about six
weeks ago
and they have no clue what's going on
they've lost ballots
there's fraudulent ballots
it's how are you going to do that for an
entire nation
now it is true that the new york
situation is not good
but the problem is not an issue of fraud
it's a logistical problem and it relates
to postmarks and last minute mailings by
the city of new york
this doesn't excuse the problem there
are problems
around the country whenever we have a
presidential election with in-person
voting voter suppression
voter rolls all of this stuff and many
of those problems are by design
there are concerns here legitimate ones
and we have similar concerns about
in-person voting as well
but this is all fixable stuff and trump
is framing it all as proactive
fraud the post office has said they are
more than equipped to handle the volume
of ballots that's expected in the fall
but trump is trying to kneecap the post
office so in other words trump is trying
to cause problems rather than solve them
and then point to the problems he plans
to exacerbate as reasons why we
shouldn't do
expanded absentee ballot access which is
essentially what we're talking about
no you know trump's trying to create
this false distinction between
vote by mail and absentee ballot and
while in theory they could be two
different things
in practice for november we're talking
about expanding absentee
let's continue they're using covert to
try and get
the mail-in ballots now absentee ballots
are great
absentee ballots they have to request
them they go through a process they get
them
but the universal mail-in ballots have
turned out to be a disaster and
what nevada has been doing if you look
over the last few days
you have to look at what they've done
you can have two ballots
you can harvest it's harvesting so you
can take
thousands of ballots put them together
and just dump them down on somebody's
desk
after a certain period of time they have
something where if you vote
the vote can count up to seven days
later well if the vote's going to count
seven days later that means you you know
if
if it depends on the one state like
nevada
that would mean simply that you can't
have supposing it's down to that one
state it could be
it's a great state but supposing it's
down to that one state
that means you have to wait seven days
again
absentee versus vote by mail uh
the request process etc we're talking
here
about letting anybody vote absentee who
wants to that's what we're talking about
it's not a new system and i'm going to
keep repeating this
endlessly because it has been debunked
it is a distinction that doesn't
really exist in practice and then trump
goes to
again you might not know the results on
election night so what
so what trump is saying both that it's
going to be rigged
and he wants the results right away well
is it the worst thing in the world
if it took a few days and we were sure
that we got the
right results that account for the
absentee ballots and we know every vote
has been counted it doesn't sound so bad
let's keep going but they won't have it
there this is something that's
so messed up and by the way i have to
say the post office
for many many years has been you know
run in a fashion that hasn't been great
great workers and everything but they
have old equipment very old equipment
and i don't think the post office is
prepared for a thing like this you have
to ask the people at the post office but
how can the post office be expected to
handle they have regular mailing
and then now on top of that they have
the internet where you have
amazon and these companies doing you
know all the buying instead of going to
a department store they go
buy through mail so you have massive
numbers of
purchases now going through the post
office purchases of items and gifts
and that's a tremendous strain on the
post office the post office loses a
fortune it has been for many many years
for decades so now on top of it has this
and
the amazons of the world and the others
they pay very very little money they
lose money on every the post office
loses money which is ridiculous
on every package it delivers but now on
top of that
and i'm not just referring to amazon i'm
talking about all of the
competitors if there is such a thing to
amazon
there will be so while he's weighing in
on e-commerce
trends there donald trump also throws in
that the post office couldn't handle the
volume of mail-in votes
again the post office has said we can
handle it just fine they've put out a
statement saying so but donald trump
wants to prevent them from being able to
handle it
by cutting their funding which is what
his new postmaster general seems
determined to do louis de joy
who is a trump donor and trump is still
going he's still ranting and lying here
but if there is such a thing but now on
top of that
you'll have somebody like the governor
of nevada
come out with this massive plan out of
nowhere
to take millions of ballots and send
them all over the place
you'll never know who won that state
it'll get messed up just like new york
and just like paterson new jersey and
just like many other places
in west virginia they indicted a a
postman
for doing something very bad you know
that
and but there are many cases all over
the country if you look
you'll be able to find there's a list of
them all over the country
and that has to do with universal
mail-in now this is important
when trump and others cite the few
examples of actual mail-in ballot fraud
those are people who got caught the
system worked
the people didn't get away with it there
were very few examples
and the people got caught that means
that the fraud
was not something they got away with it
was attempted
fraud which was caught this is like
saying
smoke detectors sometimes detect a house
fire
so we shouldn't build houses because
they're not safe no no no no
the smoke detector worked which allows
us
to safely have the houses five minutes
straight
of lie after lie after lie thanks to a
softball question from trump-friendly
media sycophants in the back of the room
it's not dissimilar from north korean
propaganda now
getting to the end of this again i mean
it's just exhausting
with vote by mail versus absentee again
absentee is great it works like in
florida
they'll do absentee it really works but
universal mail-in
ballots is going to be a great
embarrassment to our country
well i have the right to do it we
haven't gotten there yet but we'll see
what happens we will be
suing in nevada and that's already been
taken care of we'll probably file
something tomorrow
i do want to say that we're going to be
introducing a tremendous health care
plan sometime
prior hopefully prior to the end of the
month it's just about completed now
and that's the final point trump
apparently does think he can just make a
presidential decree about vote by mail
but he can't remember that states run
their own elections
they can do as they please within the
law trump can try to sue
but he can't just cancel vote by mail
from the oval office
notice by the way trump does bring up at
the end there
his new health care plan supposedly that
was going to be signed into law 48 hours
ago
now he says it'll be signed into law by
the end of
august that should really be a hoot so
five straight minutes of lying
uh we'll have more of this on our
instagram page
david pakman show on instagram follow us
there
after the break how to vote by mail it's
not tough
it's really not difficult let me tell
you real quick about one of our sponsors
cuts clothing they offer super quality
men's
t-shirts and they're giving you 15
percent off
when you go to davidpakman.com
cuts that's c-u-t-s because
solid color t-shirts are a really
important staple in pretty much every
guy's wardrobe
i think it's really important not to
overlook the value of having t-shirts
you love wearing
t-shirts from cuts clothing have been a
game changer for me and as a company all
they deal with
are men's solid color t-shirts so they
actually put a ton of thought into the
comfort the style the durability of the
t-shirts they make
they fit perfectly they're not scratchy
they don't shrink they don't fade they
don't stretch out over time like so many
other t-shirts they're really the most
comfortable t-shirts i've owned
and they look great this right here that
i'm wearing
on youtube is the split hem
crew neck t-shirt very soft
fits me perfectly it's the ideal length
go take a look at what they offer and
once you have it
you are really going to see and feel the
difference
their slogan is it's the only shirt
worth wearing
you will see why and you'll get 15
percent off when you do it
by going to davidpakman.com cuts
that's davidpakman.com c-u-t-s